-There's a lot to go over,
so let's jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
♪♪
First up, the stock market.
People on Reddit started buying
stock in GameStop as a joke,
and it caused so much chaos
that some C.E.O.s
want trading to be halted.
People can't keep their eyes off
the market right now.
You know what else people
can't keep their eyes off of?
"Bridgerton."
It's officially the most-watched
series in Netflix history,
with 82 million viewers.
The characters are high-society
Londoners, so fancy and proper.
They're kind of like people
who wouldn't be caught dead at
the new Margaritaville Resort
in Times Square.
It's coming later this year.
It has an outdoor pool,
rooftop views,
and a giant Statue of Liberty
holding a margarita.
If you ask me,
the whole thing seems...nuts.
Yeah, there's
a Grape-Nuts shortage.
The company says
it's difficult to produce
the cereal right now, and
most stores are out of stock.
What's happening?
Are stocks going up, down?
It feels like Reddit
took a hammer to the market,
and now the
system's totally smashed.
And if you want to get
totally smashed, why not try...
the Margaritaville Resort
in Times Square.
You probably shouldn't swim
with a bunch of drunk strangers,
but do your thing.
I'll be on my couch,
sipping tea and watching...
"Bridgerton."
It's a great show.
There's romance, scandal,
and, in that
classic British fashion,
the humor is really dry.
But not nearly as dry as...
Grape-Nuts, everyone's
favorite gravel-based cereal.
The company is suffering,
and that's why we should all...
buy now!
Get it while it's low.
There can be as rich as everyone
on "Bridgerton."
In conclusion...
it's taking a hit...
it's full of Brits...
it's a spoonful of grit...
Elmo's about to get lit.
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
First up,
it's St. Patrick's Day.
The big parade might not be
happening this year.
But that doesn't mean
you can't celebrate the Irish
with some corned beef
and cabbage
that you bought
using the money from...
your stimulus check.
Biden says 100 million people
will receive $1,400
or more in the next 10 days.
Though I have a feeling a lot of
them will blow their money on...
March Madness.
People are making bets
left and right.
Who will make it to
the Sweet 16, the Final Four?
Who will go all the way?
Well, if you want to go all
the way, why not try...
Tinder?
The app is in the news
because they're mailing
free COVID tests to people,
so they can be safe
before going on dates.
Some users like the idea,
others think it's weird,
but one idea
everyone can get behind?
Stimulus checks.
Gimme that stimmy.
That moolah.
That cold, hard cash.
That cheddar. That paper.
That lettuce.
That...green.
Green beer. Green hair.
Green clothes.
Some people pinch you
if you're not wearing green.
And they're the kind of people
you should avoid on...
Tinder.
You can get tested before a big
date, and let's be honest,
you should probably get
"tested" after, too.
Though I've got to say, dating
right now seems like complete...
madness -- 68 teams
vying for the top spot.
A bunch of college kids
going at it,
which is also a great way
to describe...
Tinder.
In conclusion...
you're in luck.
Good luck out there.
You might get lucky.
[Irish accent]
It's the luck o' the Irish.
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
First up, the Masters.
The tournament
kicked off this week,
and professional golfers
from all over the world
are in Georgia.
I just hope they all got...
the vaccine.
One in four Americans
has already gotten theirs,
and that's more than
60 million people.
Yeah. 60 million.
Which is also
the number of new...
Taylor Swift albums.
This is her third album
in less than a year.
Some of her songs are hopeful,
some are heartbreaking.
If you'd like
your heart to break,
why not try...
Jimmy Dean's new
Breakfast Nuggets.
I mean, if you want to wake up
first thing in the morning
and burn your mouth
on some microwave nuggets,
you must be pretty...
fearless.
Yep.
Taylor re-recorded
her hit album.
Long story short,
she's reclaiming her old songs
because she lost
the rights to the...
Masters.
There's Brooks Koepka,
Rory McIlroy, Jordan Spieth.
They might have weird names,
but they get the job done.
Kind of like...
the vaccines.
Some people have reported
feeling sore and woozy
after their second dose,
which is also how you'll feel
after eating...
Jimmy Dean's new
Breakfast Nuggets.
In conclusion...
you're number one...
two flavors...
three great options...
"Fore!"
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
First up, Prince William
and Kate Middleton
have launched
their own YouTube channel.
They plan to upload videos,
though it's not clear how often.
They could post every day
or they could post...
once every 17 years.
That's right.
The cicadas are back.
Experts are expecting trillions
of these loud, obnoxious bugs
to emerge from underground,
just in time for...
Mother's Day.
[ Laughter ]
It's this weekend, so if
you haven't bought a gift,
you should get on that.
Though, Mom would be happy
with whatever you get her
as long as it isn't...
a taco with a cigarette inside.
That's right, a woman says
she found a damp cigarette
in her Taco Bell meal.
That's disgusting.
To be honest,
I'd rather find a...
cicada.
They only pop up
once every 17 years,
so it's easy to forget
about them.
But it's okay, as long as
you don't forget about...
Mother's Day.
I mean, how could you?
Flowers, cards, chocolates --
Mother's Day stuff
is everywhere.
No matter where you turn,
you can't escape it.
It's kind of like...
the royal family.
Every TV show and movie
is about them,
and now they're taking over
YouTube, too.
I can't wait to see their first
prank video, when they...
put a cigarette
in someone's taco.
What a terrible meal.
It is the opposite
of what you'll get on...
Mother's Day,
and you get to eat it in bed.
So, in conclusion...
this should be fun...
there's gonna be a ton..
Mom, you're number one...
think outside the bun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
First up, the WNBA champions,
the Seattle Storm.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They visited President Biden
today, and get this --
they're the first WNBA team
to be invited to the White House
since 2015.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a pretty big deal.
Speaking of storms
that are a pretty big deal...
tropical depression Henri.
[ Laughter ]
Over the weekend,
45 million people were
under a tropical storm warning,
so, last week, things on the
East Coast were hot and sticky
and, this week,
things were just wet.
[ Laughter ]
And if you want something
that's just hot, wet,
and sticky, why not try...
Starbucks' pumpkin spice latte?
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's back.
Starting tomorrow.
Some people are excited,
while others think
it's too early
for pumpkin spice.
Either way, drinking one
is way better than...
eating a pizza covered
in nuts and bolts.
A woman reportedly ate half
of her Domino's pizza
before finding them
in her toppings.
Can you imagine digesting
all that cheese and metal?
I mean, that would rock you
like a...
hurricane that was...
[ Laughter ]
...downgraded
to a tropical depression.
Sure, it doesn't feel good
to be demoted,
but keep your head up, Henri.
If you work hard
and do your best,
you, too, can be the...
Storm invited
to the White House.
The team took pictures
with the Bidens,
and, of course, a lot of the
players are taller than them.
And, if you want something tall,
that's from Seattle, why not try
Starbucks' pumpkin spice latte.
It's only five bucks for a tall.
So, it'll be on the house,
if you...
find nuts and bolts in it.
If that woman sues Domino's,
she could probably
make a lot of money.
I bet she could even...
make it rain.
Henri broke the record
for rainfall
in one hour in New York,
which is nuts.
And bolts.
In conclusion...
OMG...
FYI...
PSL...
FML.
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
First up, the Justice for J6
rally tomorrow.
Right-wing protesters
will flock to Washington
to protest how the January 6th
rioters are being treated.
Some people are worried things
could get out of hand,
like last time.
Speaking of things
getting out of hand...
Nicki Minaj.
[ Laughter ]
It all started when she skipped
the Met Gala
because she's unvaccinated.
She tweeted that she's
on the fence about the vaccine
because it supposedly gave
her cousin's friend
swollen testicles.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
[ Fresh laughter ]
Speaking of things blowing up...
[ Laughter ]
Lil Nas X
is really having a moment.
[ Cheers and applause ]
His debut album
just dropped and it is great.
It starts with the hit song
"Montero,"
followed by a new song
called "Dead Right Now."
And, if you want to be
dead right now, why not try
Sam Adams' new beer
that's 28% alcohol?
It's illegal in 15 states.
I mean, drink one glass
of this stuff, and you're gone.
You might even start thinking
it's a good idea to attend the
Justice for J6 rally.
[ Laughter and applause ]
President Trump says
the rally is a "setup,"
and, now,
a lot of people are on edge.
Regardless of what happens,
there's no doubt
the whole thing is...
nuts.
There's a lot of misinformation
out there,
but experts say
the vaccine is safe.
You know what's not safe?
Sam Adams' new beer.
One sip,
you'll be upside-down, naked,
and singing at the top
of your lungs, kind of like...
Lil Nas X.
He's everywhere right now.
He even managed to make his way
to the Met Gala,
which basically is just a...
big ball.
In conclusion...
just relax...
love the tracks...
check the facts...
[Slurring] You're my best
friend. You know that?
[Normal voice]
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
First up, "Squid Game."
Netflix says it's on track
to be their biggest show ever.
If you haven't seen it,
you should check it out,
though it might be hard
to understand,
if you don't have subtitles on.
Speaking of things
that are hard to understand...
the debt ceiling.
[ Laughter ]
Are we raising it,
are we lowering it?
What's going on?
It's dominated
the news cycle all week
and it's got everyone
stressed out.
It almost makes you want
to just curl up in a ball and
listen to Adele.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Her first song in six years
comes out next week.
She released a teaser
for the song,
and everyone's
really excited for it.
You know what no one's
excited for?
Grey Poupon Wine.
Yeah, it's made with grapes
and mustard seeds.
I'm not sure
who this appeals to.
I mean,
I don't want to drink it.
To be honest, I'd rather just
sign up to play...
"Squid Game."
It's intense. Hundreds of people
fighting to the death
to pay off their debts.
They're crying.
They're screaming.
They're a total wreck.
Kind of like everyone
when they...
listen to Adele.
The teaser for her song
is only 20 seconds long,
but it has
over 8 million views.
It's called "Easy on Me."
And you know what hasn't
been easy on me?
Understanding the debt ceiling.
Congress has agreed
to raise it for two months
by $480 billion,
which is also how much
you need to pay me to try...
Grey Poupon Wine.
No one wants to pay
for mustard that gets you drunk.
You know what else
no one wants to pay for?
Raising the debt ceiling. Again.
But, hey, Congress, if you're
still strapped for cash,
there's always...
"Squid Game."
In conclusion...
here we go...
need more dough..
awesome show...
just no.
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
First up, the supply chain.
President Biden just met with
several companies
like Walmart, Target, and FedEx
to discuss solutions,
and it's not looking great.
But you know
who is looking great?
Paul Rudd.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was named "People's"
Sexiest Man Alive. Good for him.
He's universally beloved.
He makes us all laugh.
But if you prefer someone
who's universally beloved
and makes us all cry,
there's always...Adele.
She just debuted a new song
in an Amazon holiday commercial,
and it's fantastic.
The song is called "Hold On,"
and it's all about
not giving up.
But if you want to give up,
why not try...
Arby's new French Fry Vodka/
They're releasing two bottles,
and apparently,
they have the same
"flavor profile"
as their curly
and crinkle-cut fries.
[ Laughter ]
I don't understand
how that would even work.
Speaking of things I don't
understand...the supply chain.
[ Laughter ]
Shipping, trucking, inflation.
All of it has people
really stressed out.
But it's going to be okay.
Just take a deep breath,
pour yourself some wine...
and listen to Adele.
The new album drops next week.
Her first album was "19."
We loved that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then "21." Loved that.
Then "25." And now "30."
We're really -- we've really
seen her grow up over the years.
You know who hasn't grown up?
Paul Rudd.
I mean, look at the guy.
He -- He only gets better
with age.
You know what doesn't
get better with age?
Arby's Vodka.
I -- I just don't get it.
I mean, from the vodka itself
to the label,
all the way to the...
bottleneck.
Everything's
completely backed up.
So it'll affect prices.
And if you order anything
online, be prepared to...
hold on.
In conclusion...
what a guy...
time to cry...
low supply...
just why?
This has been a "News Smash."